this is a production of cornell
university
thank you much pauline thank you very
much it's a pleasure to be in person
speaking
to
you all which uh i've been
locked on zoom for a lot of the time but
this is nice
so when i was asked to do this talk i
thought about how to kind of think about
uh presenting a lot of my work and i
thought i could kind of zoom in on
zooming on one particular project like
we would typically do for a seminar or i
can give you a
long
vision of what we've done over 42 years
and uh so i thought it would do the
latter which took me a while to pare it
down to make a reasonable story and so
that's what i'm going to do i'm going to
try to tell you what has been the
objectives and the impetus and the
projects that the urban horticulture
institute which i started in 1980
has been doing for the last 40 years
more and more we're recognizing that
trees and urban vegetation have
tremendous ecological
environmental benefits for
cities we're getting more and more press
about this and in terms of the ecosystem
benefits that these uh vegetation
provide for people is quite significant
in terms of stormwater reduction air and
water quality
energy conservation cooling
carbon sequestration
urban heat island mitigation habitat for
pollinators wildlife and many more
but these are being recognized and
quantified in many cases um
so in fact uh come
late
uh april this year
into for about two or three weeks you'll
see these tags on trees in the ag quad
and you may have seen them before we've
done them for five years or so
which is quantifying the environmental
economic benefits that can be quantified
for
a
storm water for air quality for
atmospheric carbon sequestration uh
cooling and so on and we can quantify
that and we can do it over some number
of years and give the tree a
a numerical dollar value in terms of
what it's doing for the environment of
course there are many more
values to the
trees than just ones we can quantify
monetarily but it does help when you're
trying to make the case especially to
legislators
and planting departments that you know
these trees will pay you back
and they're not objectively a cost
so we'll be doing that on a tree-by-tree
basis and you'll see that this program
that we work on was from the uh
forest service and we called small i big
t-r-e-e i-tree so we work on that
program to quantify this
um but on a large scale
uh trees and vegetation lower surface
and air temperatures
shaded surface may be you know 20 to 45
degrees
uh
cooler than
uh than unshaded materials
new york city was receiving five dollars
and 60 cents of benefits for every one
dollar
it spent to plant and maintain trees
and based on this cost and analysis
mayor bloomberg
decided new york should substantially
increase his urban forest he started the
million trees project
which was supposed to be finished in
2017 it was actually finished in 2016.
223 220 000 street trees and many more
trees and other public spaces and
private spaces were put in
but after three years
thirty percent of the street trees died
or were missing
missing
where did they go
and a new tree planting initiative has
been proposed by the new mayor
eric adams so
we always love to plant trees you know
it's great
let's plant trees but we don't want to
have 30 or more missing
after we do the the nice thing about
planting trees so a lot of what i'm
talking about will be keeping those
trees going
so there's another large scale issue
about trees which is the legacy of
redlining if you're not familiar with
redlining it's lower income and racial
and ethnic minorities were denied loans
and forced to live in crowded and poor
quality housing with little investment
in infrastructure this started in the
early 20th century
and was outlawed about 50 years ago
but the legacy of that
uh which you can see in los angeles here
this is a redline community
with wider streets fewer places for
trees poorer housing more crowded
housing and in the
wealthier areas of los angeles you see a
lot of tree
uh value there a lot of cooling shading
and so this is a in the legacy of that
practice which has now been outlawed for
50 years still lives on in our cities
and it's not just all los angeles it's
everywhere every big cities
so deny loans have to live in more
crowded and multi-family housing
and very little
uh
infrastructure investment
so that's some of the the things we need
to think about
because the urban environment is
complicated we want trees we want to
have these benefits
and more and more we're recognizing that
the benefits do exist but having to
create the spaces and the trees to
actually have this happen is a
complicated process so
um
because the urban environment is so
complicated i sort of had to hang my hat
on some basic objectives where we're
going to spend our time our
graduate students efforts uh
over the many years and so i came to
hang my hat on this process which is a
landscape establishment which starts
with site assessment what do you got
where are you what in terms of your soil
like in terms of what the conditions are
like
and then
what's the proper plant for that site
now this used to be the big
uh right plant in the right place and
that's where it was stopped but we
recognized that the site itself may be
so modern so limiting that you can't
just
honk a tree in there and hope for it's
gonna
live
so
site modification
feeds into plant selection the better
the site the more chance more uh
diversity of plants you can do and we
also talked about nursery production
propagation breeding evaluation all that
goes into plant selection
and then finally transplanting getting
the tree off to a good start the first
couple of years that's what i felt we
should really
emphasize our work on because that's
where most the problems existed
we can plant trees walk away and very
often thirty percent are missing three
years later
so site assessment we're going to go
understand the opportunities and
limitations we live in a place where
there's development where there's
building even on the cornell campus
amazing amount of
construction goes on which has an effect
on the soil and so we need to understand
that especially soil is a big issue
and if we look at the big picture here's
new york state showing the usda
hardiness zones if you're not familiar
that's the average minimum winter
temperature
over a 30-year period but this was an
old one but it has good colors but you
see new york is very varied we have the
uh the tundra the adirondacks
into the the tropics of long island
because there are big bodies of water
and our topography we are very very so
the average minimum winter temperature
how cold does it get in the winter and
you need to know that
if you're going to be choosing plants
they're going to obviously want to make
it through to the next season
but what's interesting in terms of
what's happening with this
is that um
this is a
this is a 25-year average of winter
temperatures over the united states and
we see where it's beige here you can see
basically that's the same it's been the
same for many years where it's pink is
where things have gotten warmer in the
winter
so here we are in new york state and
where we are our winter temperatures
have gotten warmer by one zone which
could be 10 degrees
warmer
at our average minimum winter
temperature so you need to know most of
the country the winter temperatures are
getting warmer
and that has an effect on what trees you
plant what uh other things in terms of
uh pollinators and so on
so that's the sort of big picture and
but we want to get to the microclimate
i often say that
we've had climate change in the urban
environment
from before the word climate change was
a
on everybody's lips
because of the microclimates we find in
our cities
reflected
reflected heat
uh increases temperature decreases
humidity increases water stress
and we often talk about the urban heat
island this happens in fresno california
where you see uh
the hours of the day
and temperature and the red line is the
urban
core of fresno there you can see it's
after midday you get much higher spike
in the urban core temperature which
continues on into the evening
and uh
actually if i can digress for a minute
uh don recall here who was my graduate
student in 1983
um or so where um
we did a project in new york city
streets
uh columbus avenue and we would take
temperatures and tree data
with tom whitlow for for 24 hours we i'd
take the night shift and time to do the
day shift we have our parameters and
light cores out there and we would take
on all kinds of data and uh it was warm
at night i mean so we were taking
situations where we had lots more heat
and uh
stress on the trees through the night
time
we'll tell you a story about that
another time
yeah
so i love this infrared camera picture
which shows the heat of the surface with
a camera
and so you can kind of zoom in on that
those
vertical elements there those are trees
right
and here's the
temperature scale so anywhere from 67 to
105 fahrenheit under the trees you have
dark blue
67 degrees what's that
hey
you know i don't have to have new zoom
now so i can say what's that and you can
all say
shade
and then here in the park
in the
outside of the shade you have grass
and you're basically 82 degrees there on
the surface of the grass and what do you
think this thing is here this orange
concrete asphalt
paving right
and it's 105 degrees
and you think about all the paving all
the streets all the cars all the
reflected buildings that increases our
urban heat island significantly
i like this is a sacramento california
you see these little lollipops here
um
so there were there are ordinances in
many cities that require shade on a
parking lot 10 20
and they put them in with the big
pictures saying oh this is she's going
to get those big it's going to look
great and it's going to shade all the
cars
but those trees never got any bigger
than what they look like there's reasons
for that
but then basically what they were
dealing with impervious surfaces is
estimated at 40 000 square miles about
316
added annually and that's probably an
underestimate because that was data
taken a few years ago
so this is a big issue that we have to
deal with
but in terms of above ground uh site
assessments one thing below ground is
much more significant and something we
can do something about
so dealing with the soil
and you might recognize this place
do they recognize this
yeah
what is it
man library yeah yeah that's like it's
actually it's a whole ag quad when i was
being
renovated and you know
we had cars we had trucks we had
materials just everywhere which changes
the soil particularly compacting the
soil which then when they pull out we
have the legacy of that to deal
with
so we measure that with penetrometers
we'll field looking at the density of
soil and we'll also be taking bolt
density which is a very important
measure of how
tight the soil is to allow or not allow
roots to get into it
both density is a big issue that we deal
with all the time
and then when you have dense soil and
this is wegmans parking lot
when they were doing some work i got in
there after a rainstorm and water was
just sitting there it's our bathtub
no drainage no porosity
so in fact when we plant a nice red oak
you wonder why is it dying
because his roots are sitting in water
and red oaks don't like
the roots and now you could have changed
those species and had a tree that would
deal with that
but no one really recognized the
pros and cons of this
and of course we also have issues of
nutrition
particularly higher ph in urban areas
because of the building materials that
leach
into the
soil and we have chlorosis ion chlorosis
here with oaks as you see here which is
a common thing
and you know sometimes within
15 feet you can have tree that does well
and the one that's doing poorly and you
think what is going on because of all
these different microclimate
effects and soil effects
trees can do very very differently
within a very short space
and so if the trees could talk
what would they say
so okay so how do we deal with this
so we have
genetic potential of a tree and an
environmental reality nature nurture
okay we have to deal with both of those
things we have to choose the right tree
we have to
understand the environment and modify it
if we can to make it better for trees to
grow the better we match up that the
better results are going to be
so let's talk about plant selection a
little bit because oh it's a part that
everybody loves oh trees are beautiful
um
so after many many years they're
basically four criteria i think about
use for selecting trees
and they're not necessarily hierarchical
you can start any place in this first we
need pest resistant plants adapted to
environmental conditions that's abiotic
conditions
we need to have highly diverse native
and non-native non-invasive trees
we want to talk about natives versus
non-natives that's another talk another
time
uh it meets design and functional
objectives what do you want to do street
trees screens
forests whatever you want to do in terms
of why you're planting the tree and it
has to match
management limitations what needs to be
done can you get it can you find it is
the big size is it have pruning
necessary what kinds of things you need
to do and can you
provide that
service to the trees so these four
factors are very important
and people who always ask me what's the
perfect tree
for what's the best tree
you know you're
studying this for a long time what's the
best tree for my city i said well we
knew what the best tree was
1930s there's the
clock tower
this of course close to traffic that's
the american l ole miss americana which
was planted all over
the northeast midwest because it was
incredibly tough tree easy to transplant
tolerance wet and dried flood plain
species high up in the soil no problem
it just and it grew fast and it was
beautiful and created these arches that
were famous
uh but then
because of lack of diversity
same clock tower
uh
1950s i don't know if you know the
probably the cars will tell you
all those gone
and they were all over the corner campus
in fact i was an undergraduate in um
uh 1971 to 74
and when i left in 74 there were still a
couple of elms on the ag squad
but they're on the way out
so
no more elms
and we have a really flat learning curve
really flat
so here's that same clock tower
and now we have
one species one cultivar
in that
portion of campus
now and they look great
uh but what happens if some particular
insect disease diseases i like london
planes
this would be a disaster
so diversity is key
and if we look at new york state
we have 4.2 million street trees in new
york state
giving us 560 million dollars in
benefits
quantifiable benefits
but 60 of the street trees are from four
genera
maples
uh easter 44
7 for oaks
5 for honey locusts
and 4 for lindens
for genera making up 60
of the street shoes in new york and
that's a
real you know a very uh issue an issue
where it can be very very destructive
and we've seen this with particular you
know emerald ash borer with an asian
longhorn beetle with really indulgent
with insect pests that come around and
because we have so much food for them
they really take off
so this is a
just a basic common sense we need to
have more diversity
but one of the things we've been looking
at to try to
evaluate trees for their ability to
tolerate wet and dry soils which is
typical of urban environments and
exacerbated by climate change is looking
for plants adaptations to limited water
available and you can put it in two
categories one is avoidance
i don't wanna
basically like
avoidance of water limitations or
tolerance of water limitations
and in many cases there's both
interacting for trees
but for avoidance you're basically
maximizing water acquisition reducing
water use
stomatal closure reduce growth and
increase hydraulic conductivity these
are all
avoidance mechanisms
tolerance is where basically the plant
is experiencing drought but is able to
osmotically adjust
to keep the water in the cells keep the
turgor so that they can keep
photosynthesizing even the face of
drought
so
some colleagues from sweden and the uk
worked on that with me and we'll talk to
you about tolerance in a minute this is
a
uh telethomatosa silver linden it's a
great tree native of eastern europe
much more tolerant of drought than some
of the other lindens we use and you
notice the white underside the backstill
surface of the leaf giving its common
name
we look more carefully at this
you can see these trichomes on their
backsill surface
basically covering up a lot of the
stomates
so they're basically creating a barrier
for water loss
that's giving the tree a little
advantage in terms of keeping the water
in the tree
that's really neat picture like amoeba
and of course this is the fall color of
that tree and so it's a great tree
uh has a lot of these avoidance
mechanisms that allow it to do well
now the tolerance mechanisms uh
we're looking at leaf target loss point
can be a useful measure to determine
which trees can do better given more and
more drought stress as the season
progresses
and so again this was a work that uh
colleagues of mine from uh uk and sweden
worked on for many years
and just show you a
listing of 27 maple
taxa um
the idea here is that we're looking at
the the negative turbo loss point the
more negative it is the better it's able
to hold water before it loses turgor
okay
so the more negative the better and we
did it in spring which is the dark bar
and then summer because trees naturally
adapt over the season
and we're looking at some species that
have quite
quite low turbo loss points this one
monspecialenum is from turkey
very small leaves really tight uh then
but this one granite dentatum is big
tooth maple from the western part of the
united states which is hardly used here
but it maybe should be um hey so
specatom really down
this is a
tree that's native here in the gorges of
tremen remember walking around there and
saying what maple is this i never see
this on the street and it's a mountain
maple ace of spacatum and it's very very
intolerant of water loss drought
so we can kind of look at these and the
more you get over let's say three
you're basically looking at a tree
that's more able to tolerate water loss
over the common time so these are useful
ways of evaluating trees
uh
doing this in a lab taking samples doing
it in the lab and then
finding out the
uh
the issues here
so another thing we've done in terms of
tree selection is look at develop hybrid
oaks now the general quercus is noted to
be very very tolerant it's a very varied
torrent of stress
and we were looking at um
within the white oak sub-genera looking
love to create trees that would be more
tolerant of alkaline soils and drought
and still have good tree form
so between 2004 2006 we actually made
crosses
of uh
five maternal parents on the cornell
campus and we got pollen from all over
the world
and pollinated of the white oak group
and pollinated these maternal parents at
cornell
and after several years in 2008
we uh
planted them out each individual
genotype is in one of these plants
and then we started well when some of
them may have good qualities we want to
be able to propagate them so we did some
work on propagation of oaks which i'll
show you here basically using we cut
back the trees
we evaluate the shoots they grow out in
the dark
cutting back is critical you have to get
to the really juvenile part of the stem
to have this work
and then edulation
and as the idiolater shoes are sized we
take a paintbrush and paint the back the
bottoms of those with iba about 8 000
parts per million in ethanol
and then we shade the plants with this
mesh trash can for a week while they
green up
and we put a collar
with soilless mix around these new
shoots which have been painted and we
let them grow up
for about four or five months
and hopefully they're going to root
from the stump
uh and
sometimes we're really lucky so this is
what happens after about four or five
months you see the roots coming from the
base of those
stems you can take them off and the
stump is still there to
go again the next year
uh so this was great we were wrote it up
very happy about this
first time really clonally propagating
uh oaks you know mass scale but
so if i want to get this to a nursery
man and start to produce these
every year i get about three rooted
shoots
so do the math not very good
from the point of
but it was a definitely a first step
four
and we also evaluated them for these
shoots for alkalinity tolerance looking
at the issues of chlorosis
with a spad meter
you know from really chlorotic to
reasonably green
leaves which is a big issue with some
oaks
and then these are those same trees out
at bluegrass lane
uh planted because this is a low ph soil
so they all look pretty green here
and
we planted them all over in fact over 60
communities in new york state have some
of these trees which are evaluating over
time in different soils and taking spare
readings
but this is a few that we think are
really worthwhile that might be
introduced first if we can solve a few
more propagation issues this is right
outside of men's garden to the west side
of minsk garden this is a gamble time
warsaw gamble times bur oak mom
times over cup oak dad
and we get this really kind of unusual
looking leaf very unlike any of those
parents
and it seems to be doing very well in
high ph soil it's pretty green
other couple of ones that we are
really interested in this is the
swamp white oak times english oak mound
times a live oak times over cup oak dad
so it's a four-way cross
and we also have a festive form for this
one this is in front of warren hall
there's two in front of warren
and then we have another one
swamp white oak times japanese white oak
aliena which is uh doing very well look
notice the greenness of the leaf and the
ph here is all over 7.6
so
it gives us some
confidence that these are might be good
selections to introduce the nursery we
had 305 individual genotypes when we did
this and we may get down to
10
trees that we think might be useful for
uh introducing but the issue is
getting enough
so instead of doing the propagation
message i showed you we started going
into tissue culture now no one has
really done
successfully done tissue culture of oaks
other than
occasionally so we have to massively
produce these we can get them to
multiply
and when we're lucky we can get them to
root
once we got there
then we can get them to the nurseries to
trial and
they'll do their own uh
trialing and then getting it out to the
community so this is a long-term project
when you work with trees
you got to give it time sometimes you
have five more months till
i retire but that's okay i'll still be
here doing the oaks
so okay so much for plant selection
let's just talk about quickly talk about
limits of plant selection
it's great to have you can have great
trees but if you have bad soil
it doesn't matter what kind of tree you
have so here we have two honey locusts
one on the left side going next to an
open volume of soil one on the right
side in a parking lot in a little pit
same species
and the growth is
determined by the amount of soil so this
is the other aspect of site modification
we started getting to how much soil does
a tree need
you worked on this
in the early 1990s
came up with
i was going to go through this the
formula i said that would take too long
but in general two cubic feet for every
square foot of crown projection of
envisioned crown projection not the one
you put in the ground but what you
envision over
20 30 years so we can come up with that
depending on the soil depending where
you are depending on the rainfall
all of that but then you need to say
okay
i need to prepare that soil in order to
have the size tree
i'm interested in now this
comes back to the original idea of
green equity or greening our cities
because you can plant as many trees as
you want
unless you're going to get the canopy
that's going to give you the benefits
it's basically worthless
so that's why planting tree planting is
very important but we have to create the
site that's going to allow these trees
to get to their envisioned design size
and give us ecological benefits which we
want them and here's the place we
recognize
there was when man library was being
redone you can see
what happened to the ag quad
then
and then we were cast our class was
asked to do a landscape in front of mann
library
and there was like the dumpsters and the
trucks and eventually they
they left
and so we
did
we used a pro process called scoop and
dump
or
amendment in place as opposed to
bringing in soil
this is basically applying a layer of
six to eight inches of compost to
compact the soil on top
using a backhoe to dig down to about 18
inches scooping it up and dropping it
from about three feet and we get a
basically veins of compost through the
clogs of compacted soil
we plant right into that and then mulch
every year to replenish organic matter
until we get to canopy closure where
they're creating their own organic
matter
so we've done this all over campus
probably different 20 different
everything all over the ag quad bath man
library
ilr courtyard stocking
uh
lots of places
you don't know it we've done it so this
is what it looked like the year after we
planted that front of man library the
first year
and a couple years later
and a couple years later
and so we've got the canopy closure
where leaves are falling to the ground
creating more organic matter so we don't
have to go in
and replenish organic matter but we
don't rake out anything everything stays
in the bed
the idea of raking out the leaves is
a wrong practice and that site won a
sights award that's right it's it's one
of the first 11
sites or landscapes that were
awarded a sustainable sites initiative
which is like lead for landscapes it's a
national program and this is one of
those projects that got that
certification
so scoop and dump we i'm not going to
show you the data but
poor soil resistance decreased poor
volume increased
improved bulk density
very important increased
active carbon and nitrogen improved soil
structure aggregate stability improved
plant growth and a long-term improvement
over 20 years
because we started looking at this well
what happened when we first did it in
2001
until now and so we have a lot of that
data which suggested that the soil
actually gets better
uh over time
we did study of plants though on
some of our
amendment sites and on amended sites
which are adjacent we want to look at
the
plant growth aspect specifically not
just seeing that it looked good but
creating a more experimental design
where we took uh
cores and we ran them into the soil
unamended and in amended soil we took
the same cores
and ran them to the soil we had the soil
in those cores and then we planted
uh ficus benjamina because it was in the
wintertime we needed something that was
going to grow in the winter greenhouse
and we planted
little plugs of ficus in those
amended unamended
cores
grew them in a growth chamber
again this is a whole
study of
data this you can see the uh the
compacted core so we had the original
plug roots
and the roots that went off that only
could be on the surface because
the core was so compacted so they went
to the surface and they went down the
sides of the pore
so they made a run for it but this was
the original root system these are the
compacted root systems
and this is the amended soil root system
of the same cores
and the root
roots are basically exploring every inch
of that soil getting to the whole area
going through the aggregates and so on
if we look at one piece of data
which is both density
increasing on the x-axis
and then we're looking at dry weight of
shoots
um
the amendment is green and the unamended
is as pink
you can see the shoot's weight is much
greater when you have bolt density below
1.4
versus above 1.4 and 1.4 is in the
literature said that's the threshold for
root penetration but we know it's really
a continuum it's a regression it's not
like you get to 1.4 things fall off the
edge of the earth
if you can get your bulk density down in
the kind of point eight to one you're
much better than to think about oh i'm
just 1.35 i'm okay
so you need to think about both density
it's a big driver of plant growth
okay
got a few more minutes so
this was the other issue we really
worked on was the
structural soil
question so we had compaction in the
landscape due to construction and
development but what about purposeful
compaction because of laying pavement
so here this tree ball is going to go
into that hole and we're going to say
goodbye and good luck and uh hopefully
we'll see you again
in many years but that doesn't happen so
see your structural soil was something
we developed in the late 90s and it's
been working ever since
so required compaction due to you have
to compact the subgrade we call it
subway the soil before you lay pavement
because if it's loose
uh the pavement's going to subside it's
going to crack
so you have a load-bearing surface
that's purplely done before you lay
pavement
and sometimes you actually even
reinforce it and this whole this little
space here
um
what's that going to be
what's that for
it's for a tree
okay
so we compacted this we reinforced it
and we've left this little space for a
tree to go in there
and the soil around that tree is
impenetrable
so we're putting it in a pot we're
hoping it's going to grow
so this is kind of a cross section of
that we compact the subgrade which is
all these
hatch marks we put a base course of
gravel and then the pavement
and so we hope the tree's going to get
out but very often it does not
but if it does get out it might you know
very surface surfa superficial roots
it's not getting much
penetration at all and the tree goes
over
or uh
we'll see what we did so what we did
this here
is to develop a soil
called cu structural soil which is a
basically
uh
a nod to the engineers and the nod to
the trees the compromise
these white
uh
angular pieces represent gravel of one
size
approximately one inch two centimeters
and the
because we have one size we have big
pore space
we have a well graded gravel we
use up all the floor space with smaller
gravel we're one size pretty big gravel
and in between those pieces of gravel we
have soil and water and air
and the key is to have a
gravel that
locks into place creates a rigid lattice
so you could land an airplane on it
and still have this place for roots and
soil to go in the soil in between those
angular pieces
is not compacted
the soil is not compacted so the
load is being born by the gravel this is
the concept of structural soil and
that's what some we use in this area you
can see the
angular pieces we allow from three
quarters of an inch to one and a half
inches
in size
we added this is jason garbowsky on my
right a graduate student now for
professor at rutgers who did this work
and we're adding a clay loam soil with
at least 20 clay to the structural soil
and we had to add on one more thing
which was that tackifier to the stone so
that the soil would
uh
stick and wouldn't it wouldn't have hot
spots in low and low spots wet and dry
spots so it had to be very uniform
and then we
compacted you can see roots just
shooting through
the structural soil the rigid lattice
shooting through this
so we thought we were getting somewhere
we did uh sidewalks of nowhere
uh bluegrass lane
where we uh actually
had trenches down three feet
lined with heavy mill plastic we put
structural soil or normal soil compacted
it to engineer specification laid a
sidewalk and put conal trees in there to
see how they would grow and we knew
we're going to do is take them cut them
down three years later
took the
yeah i suppose the concrete off there's
the base course the granular base course
and then we took the tree out of the
ground in one piece
using an air excavation tool
taking the whole
root system out of the ground
and not taking a sample
that's the structural soil root system
that's a normal soil root system
now just like we saw with the ficus
the roots are at the surface because
they can't get in lower down
and so this just like the ficus this is
one that came to the trench and made a
runner down the side
but we get this flat pancake roots
and that's of course what causes all the
sidewalk heaving when people say it's
the tree's fault yes it says tree's
fault but it's the way we plant trees
that creates this
and uh of course this is a big issue i
mean this litigious society millions and
millions of dollars are spent
uh
reducing lawsuits because people trip
and fall
so we looked at where trees are tree
roots are in the
urban environment and we see that
they're right at the surface
you know and they go into somebody's
front yard
they're good i mean there's a narrow
tree lawn
the trees don't have enough rooting
space so if they can make it into
somebody's
front lawn or some
other soil the trees do well
this is what we like to see as a term as
a
basically an uh
detail where structural soil is between
the building face and the tree pit
ordinary soil put into the tree
hole so we can maximize water holding
and we can have
trees get more volume
1997 first one was doing in ithaca on
route 13.
uh this is uh mlk
street down near the commons
this is structural trees and structural
soil
after eight years
this is in brooklyn
structural soil in the pits but also
between the pits which you can't see on
the top left
and after three years and after ten
years
uh three hundred three thousand five
hundred installed projects in the using
cu soil in 48 states canada ireland gb
and israel
uh also i should say uh australia
but this happens to be uh miami south
beach with structural soil in palms i
mean who to know once you get things out
there you don't know how people are
gonna use them we have multiple
brochures giving a hands-on how do you
use this
but it gets out there this is sydney
olympic site plaza
these are oriental planes in structural
soil
with irrigation because they have no
rain there so
uh
that does very well
so again a useful
uh prod use of structural soil is just
a solution to stormwater problems
this is another big project using porous
asphalt with structural soil
allowing water to filter through
recharging grain groundwater and
allowing trees to be
planted in those areas so we often see
these kind of
massive flooding events especially where
there's more and more asphalt this was
route 81 a few years ago
but the reason we could do this with
structural soil compacted to engineering
specifications
which is called proctor density
we have
tonal porosity less in structural soil
than a normal soil because we have those
big stones
which would expect less porosity but the
macro porosity the big pores 31
versus 2
of the macro porosity which gives you
drainage and infiltration rate greater
than 24 inches
or less than
0.5 inches so you can't just put porous
pavement over compacted soil it's just
not going to go anywhere it's going to
go so slow you need to have a reservoir
to collect that water
so this was a site we did on uh
ithaca where the
trail
uh trailhead the people were parking in
he said why why don't we try it here
so we put structural soil under this
entire
space compacted it
we put porous and non-porous asphalt
on top of it
if you're not familiar with that that's
porous asphalt that's non-porous asphalt
and then we saw cut into it and planted
uh bare root trees
in 2005
and that's the 2006 uh
spring
that's uh 2009
2012.
so uh they were really growing well i
mean they were getting water at least
through the at least both of them were
doing well
but we started to notice in about 2012
that the trees in the
non-porous the traditional asphalt were
not as big as those in the porous
asphalt
so non-porous
yeah a little smaller
porous asphalt
so we had to measure this we had to
decide what this was getting late here
um it took our
colleague uh
to use his ground penetrating radar to
look at where the roots were
and each of these slices
is
the number of roots and the depth okay
paths of the
ground penetrating radar the trees would
be in the middle take six slices this
way six slices that way you see each of
those red dots is a root and you can see
where they are in the profile
that's of the non-porous the traditional
asphalt
and this is the poorest asphalt
much deeper many more roots
and we think this is the reason why
those trees are doing a whole lot better
and we look at tree growth
since 2012 they were pretty much the
same but they started the ones in the
non-porous asphalt are getting smaller
so it's important to know
to get the water in the ground that's an
important piece
the last thing i'm just going to talk
about for a few minutes is transplanting
which is at four stage site assessment
plan selection
uh site modification and transplant this
is another issue
deals with diversity sometimes we want
to plant a certain tree but it
transplants very poorly
and we're looking at hydraulic
conductance
to measure the cavitation the air
bubbles that might be in the xylem tubes
which cause resistance to water flow
one minute okay
uh
basically
picture is small caliper greater
hydraulic conductance than a large
caliper and
spring better conductance than fall
so a lot of
you know uh common wisdom is that
small plants transplanted
transplant better than large ones
yeah there's a reason for it at least
this is one reason for it
we also looked at
container trees
uh this is a problem we get very often
with container grown trees we do root
pruning and we found that small caliper
trees get greater conductance when we
root pruned than when we didn't
so i'm going really fast here last thing
we did is transplanting
with bare root using a u-blade to go
under the trees and get trees out of the
ground we dipped the roots in hydrogel
to keep them from drying out put them in
bags and
uh over 100 communities in new york and
pennsylvania use this method now to
plant trees and you can see it's about
25 pounds versus 300 pounds for bnb
last two slides or so
to get all this information to
communities that need it you need to
you need to engage them so we had swat
teams steven we can arbitrage teams for
10 years
they went into 60 communities did tree
inventories and master plans and then
presented to the people whether it's the
elected people
people in dbw
arborists who were working with that
community we presented the data and
suggestions for how they might go ahead
these are some of our guys
10 years we did this
okay
but we also need to know that there are
amazing things we can do with trees in
our cities this is one of the most
beautiful pictures this happens to be
tokyo with ginkgos all ginkgos there
and this is new york city famous paley
park
really oasis in the middle of downtown
manhattan
and my last slide
there's still things we don't understand
so there's a polonia growing out of a
tree by building
that's me
a long time ago
so any questions i know i've kind of run
i've gone through a lot and i've run a
little bit long but you have questions
yeah
hi dr
thank you so much for your
presentation i wanted to ask a little
bit
about the social benefits of
trees and cities you talk a lot about
the economic benefits but what what is
it like what are the benefits and costs
to a child growing up in a concrete
jungle versus to a child growing up in a
city
that has trees well i mean this is what
don reykja is working with in terms of
nature rx
there are a lot of benefits they're not
as quantifiable as yet than the economic
and environmental benefits but i mean
having grown up in brooklyn new york i
mean i the trees the parks
were
very impre and important to get out and
play
yeah and also to be cool when you're
playing
so i know
mayor bloomberg when he says there
should be a park in new york city no
more than 10 minutes walk
that was the game so have a park
somewhere that people can get to within
10 minutes well um i'm not sure that's
all there but that they're working
toward that so i think that um there are
lots of you know
lots of boys lots more data in terms of
benefits of
trees to people that are not just
economic environmental but they're
social cognitive they're
and that's what don is going to talk to
you about sometimes
yeah question another question
i was wondering
is there a difference in cost and or
durability or complication with the um
tourist asphalt versus the
yeah so a lot of people say that porous
asphalt would break apart you know and
especially in the northern areas here
but we've found that in fact the
hospital uh has all porous asphalt there
and that's been
at least 15 years with no maintenance i
mean they say you should vacuum clean it
and all this stuff nobody does that
and it's been very very the important
thing is to put a reservoir under the
porous asphalt so the water is getting
moved down if you have water sitting at
the surface it'll break up
so is that porous whether it's just
gravel
or it's
sea or soil if you're trying to grow
trees in there you need to get the water
down from the surface what the and the
cost
the cost
of using porous versus
well the main thing is the poorest
asphalt is
regular asphalt without the fines what
the fun and so it's basically much the
same recipe
but the asphalt companies have to clean
out a whole bay
to make it and so this has to be cost
effective amount but it should it's not
really much more cost because it's just
taking away one ingredient to make the
it's like caramel corn the porous
asphalt
yeah
let's see so you talked a little bit
about diversity and diseases and i was
wondering what scales do you think it's
most appropriate to assess that
diversity
specifically spatial scales yeah so
we've typically been looking at we've
done many different
research projects on looking at
the
makeup of city street trees in cities
we did new york pennsylvania new jersey
and massachusetts we looked at all those
states
and
the scale i mean if you're looking at
just a few blocks of one species that's
probably not a big effort you have to
think if some particular disease or
insect comes down and hits that two
blocks
okay you can deal with that if so we
look at the whole city scale in terms of
diversity
because when uh
the dutch elm disease came in
all american islands were some some
cities were 70 percent
and that
arguably gave rise to the urban forestry
movement because
this trees were gone and people really
valued them so we have tended to look at
them at the community scale
not as a block by block
is that answering questions
yeah yeah but we also have another
project where we said well people
tend to want
symmetry in some ways
and especially in europe but here too so
we have methods where you can have
a
visual similar
similarity with genetic diversity by
choosing trees that look similar and our
height to first branch is the same
and for you know
students who haven't learned tree id
they don't know what the tree
yeah but
so people often don't know the
difference between history and that tree
if they look similar so there are ways
of putting things together to increase
the genetic diversity but have that
similarity if that's wanted
so we have a couple of um
questions in the chat
uh do i have one oh from anya
okay i'm sorry if the for some reason
they're not coming up if you could
please unmute and ask your question um
for
dr bosok thank you yes uh thank you so
much for this presentation it's just
incredible to see all your work laid out
like this um and i was just wondering
are your swat teams still active no the
smart teams are not still active
after 10 years
we decided that was enough
60 communities mostly in
central new york i moved had a hard time
finding more communities
to do
and basically we decided
we gave people how to do it it's all a
website community forestry website which
do you want to do it how do you do it
but we decided after 10 years
we're not doing it anymore
okay and i've got two more
spencer you want to go
sure yeah thank you so much for the
great talk really engaging i was
wondering in addition to looking at
street plantings have you done any work
to evaluate benefits of
rooftop gardens or plantings in a city
like new york
something that i've seen from my time
living there
well rooftop gardens are
i mean putting green on a roof generally
reduces the albedo the
reflectance then reduces the urban heat
island in terms of
creating
a food source on urban
trees or could be a food source or it
could be just a sedum garden
there are many
many benefits that are attached to that
but
there are also some limitations in terms
of uh nutrient-laden water going into
the
water pipes and into especially nitrogen
going into the sewers
so it's a mixed bag of benefits
putting a green roof on a roof most of
the time it's an energy
savings sometimes it's a storm water
savings although you can do that with
ballast
without plants you can have
stormwater captured
but uh
without going into a big deal there are
a lot of different pros and cons of
doing that
thank you okay did i miss anybody in the
in thanks spencer
did i miss anybody in the
chat um kate kate here um i had a
question about um
planting for the changing temperature
profiles and and the possibility of
planting
southern native species farther north is
that something
well we have done that uh in fact in
ithaca
in cornell we're at zone 5b which is
like um
minus 15 degrees minimum temperature
downtown in ithaca where 6a which is
minus 10 degrees
and so there are trees we grow down
there that probably not going to grow
well up here so we have a
quickest machoi
which is the swamp chestnut oak we have
quercus laireda which is the overcup oak
downtown
in ithaca which are growing fine and
those are southern species
and they're going perfectly well up here
so uh
we try these things sometimes we have
southern magnolia growing downtown even
southern magnolia up here um
in certain you know microclimate areas
that we can push the envelope which
because some of these lists that this is
this tree and this is some of those are
pretty general to observation and
sometimes we just need to try these
things
so we are choosing some of these other
southern trees and going into
uh at least downtown africa
okay last one marianne mccloskey
hi yeah i was interested when you said
that you allowed the leaves to drop and
stay around in the garden now in
vegetable gardening normally you're
always told to take the dead plant
matter away so that you don't um
increase
the insects and
any um
fungi that might be growing on the on
the plants so is that not an issue with
the trees then have you found they're
not not enough no i um
no it's not an issue with woody plants
which we're talking about here and some
perennial plants we basically want that
organic matter in the garden and yes
they'll have fungi and it'll have
insects but if unless they're not going
to be really
hurting the plants i mean they're just
naturally occurring in the soil and
they're breaking down the organic matter
and we want that to happen so we don't
worry about that in terms of infecting
the plants
and vegetable plants i mean it's more a
question of getting you know getting the
soil warmed up and other issues
but at least for woody plants landscape
beds we definitely want those
leaves in the beds okay thank you
sure
thank you very very much
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu